this thick blanket of smoke is known as
Southeast Asia as the haze every year
during the dry season from June to
October Indonesia sits massive forest
fires to clear land for agriculture the
resulting small periodically envelops
the country's furious Southeast Asian
neighbors including Singapore and
Malaysia deforestation creates about the
same amount of greenhouse gases each
year as cars airplanes and other modes
of transport combined perhaps
unsurprisingly then the fires have made
Indonesia one of the world's worst
global warming offenders so here's the
situation the fires come from paper and
palm oil plantations that use illegal
slash-and-burn techniques 20 times
cheaper than other methods for clearing
land Indonesia produces about half of
the world's 50 billion-dollar palm oil
crop each year which is widely used in
products like mayonnaise and makeup
there is some good news about the
world's rainforests though globally the
rate of deforestation per year has
slowed by 1/3 to about 5.2 million
hectares to put that in perspective
we've gone from destroying forests twice
the size of Belgium to the size of
Denmark a lot of that improvement can be
seen in Brazil's Amazon you can see that
in 2011 Indonesia overtook Brazil as the
number one country for forest loss now
here's the argument environmental groups
say Indonesia needs to follow the lead
of other countries that have slowed
deforestation by strengthening its
moratorium on permits Indonesia says it
needs financial help and that the
process of identifying those responsible
take time researchers estimated to take
up to a decade to stop the burning that
causes the haze